you saw nothing i wish i saw nothing
what i did see was like two baby birds
feeding each other turning red like all
of pixar's films went through a huge
development period from a general idea
to concept art to dropped plotlines and
even a few animation mistakes we're
taking a look at everything we could get
our paws on
number one just like mei was going
through changes so was the panda maze
red panda went through some pretty
drastic changes in the film originally
the panda was going to grow and shrink
depending on how emotional mei was but
this led to complications for the
animation team when deciding how big to
make her domi she said the more angry
she'd get the bigger and more feral
she'd look the size of the panda
constantly changing was going to cause
more problems for may adding even more
comedy to situations where she'd be too
small or too big do you think there is
any particular emotion attached to mei's
ears or tail popping out only we're
assuming it's just an anime thing
inspiration inuyasha in this concept art
it looks like the pandas also had
firepowers we can see why this would
complicate the whole magical puberty
thing just a bit too much but there may
have been remnants of the fire in may in
this next bit of concept art may can be
seen with what's either blue smoke or
fire coming out of her ears and tail
while we're pretty sure this idea was
replaced with the poof of pink smoke
it's still pretty cool to see and the
spiral design that's a symbol of her
great ancestor became limited to just
her arms in the end which we bet made
animating her much easier
number two we're glad they didn't
destroy all of toronto in this movie you
know how we were talking about may
changing sizes well turning red had an
alternate ending where may was going to
grow to the size of her mom's red panda
and the two were going to tear up
toronto in an epic godzilla-like battle
pretty sweet huh luckily they pared that
down to just ming being gigantic which
minimalized the damage costs they would
be on the hook to cover
number three it's amazing how plots
evolve
because speaking of damage there was an
alternate plot altogether that the final
scene of the movie showed of the family
slowly paying off the sky dome before it
became that scene it was an entire plot
in the movie where ming was the one
encouraging her daughter to turn into a
panda to raise money for their family
temple of course this manifested in more
ways than paying to repair the skydome
it also became the story of may raising
money for four town tickets
number four so you come to me on the day
of my daughter's wedding yes there was
indeed a gangster in chinatown named
benny blacktooth in the first draft of
the screenplay the temple had fallen
onto hard times and so they owed quite a
lot of money to this blacktooth
character domi she admitted the first
version was so kooky we just really went
for all out like a goofy steven chaos
kind of screwball kind of comedy but it
wound up way too complicated domi
brought this draft to a halt when she'd
said wait wait wait we were talking
about magical puberty why are there
gangsters in this they had done their
research talking to san francisco
chinatown experts who discussed the
warring chinatown gangs but we will
admit we're glad they took a different
approach it would have made the movie
far less relatable there was even this
weird bit of concept art where 13 year
old pandamay was officiating at a
gangster wedding
number five this would have made for
either a depressing story or a
completely absurd one another abandoned
draft focused far more on family and far
less on may growing up when it took
place at her grandmother's funeral in
this version she would be meeting her
extended family for the first time
meaning we would see so much more of all
those kooky ants we love so much in the
film in this draft mei and her mom have
a rivalry against a cousin and an aunt
who could still turn into their pandas
we're in love with the concept art for
the little cousin who had a tail more
like a raccoon so at one point it wasn't
only the women of the family who turned
into pandas this story was scrapped for
being too plot focused and lost sight of
may's journey through magical puberty
number six dropping the references that
today's youth wouldn't understand was a
good idea some of the names were changed
as the plot of the movie developed may
was originally named faye and four town
was called boys and streets that's right
it was spelled with a z because that was
the cool thing in the era of boy vans
that and all things numbers there was at
least 20 different titles for turning
red too from the notorious rpg rpg
meaning red panda girl a play on the
name of the rapper my neighbor toronto a
play on my neighbor totoro pms panda
mayhem syndrome you can figure that one
out girl in red panda prime anything but
red big deal and faily and a panda to
name a few
number seven saving the planet one cut
scene at a time we completely lost one
scene that was fully animated that was
included in the trailer and the making
of documentary on disney plus may and
her friends were protesting to save the
planet in the making of doc we lost this
weird little moment of the girls
flopping on the floor in an attempt to
draw attention to their cause this was
most likely cut due to it not reflecting
mei's goody two-shoes straight a values
it was better to highlight how perfect
she is in that she wasn't even
attempting to disrupt the system but
that doesn't mean the environment isn't
important guys just that may doesn't
seem like the type to protest we do
however see how it made it to completion
before being cut
number eight the beavers are not happy
about this one there was a quirky
canadian joke that wound up being
replaced with a just as quirky triangle
joke tragically we lost the line are you
a beaver cause damn
and instead we got are you a triangle
cause you were cute
the geometry joke works fine but we're
still sad about it hey maybe a red panda
would be attracted to a beaver who knows
and maybe that would take the magical
puberty metaphor a step too far for a
children's movie hmm
number nine these are just the scrapped
pages they were willing to show us some
pages were drafted up for may's notebook
that we never even got to see including
a page of devin as a centaur and all of
may's friends dressed up as sailor moon
characters this bit was a nod to one of
the major influences of the film the
anime style and pastel colors of sailor
moon were the color palette they used in
turning red another reference to sailor
moon can be seen hanging on the wall in
this concept art including everybody's
favorite number two character luigi with
toad not that we ever expected the
characters to make it into the movie
given the ip isn't owned by disney but
it's still cute to see did you know domi
she's parents still have some of her
drawings that influenced the notebook
scene
number 10. it's like a light bulb one
day it's off the next day we're obsessed
that's a pretty bad metaphor unless
you're a moth we can all relate to this
one i didn't even like sport time last
year but now they're literally the
greatest thing this scene we imagine was
in the opening shot of the movie where
may's narrating if this was staged at
her house it makes sense to cut it
because of course ming is not a huge fan
of may's friend group hip-hoppers and
why are they called fourth town if there
are five of them
number eleven and speaking of watching
tv there's also this sweet bit of
concept art of mei and ming crying while
holding each other and watching tv we
did get a truncated version of this in
the movie and there was no crying
involved instead they were sassing the
poorly contrived plot of the show
leading to the assumption that they're
watching some sort of soap opera
number 12 which makes for better
character development only child
syndrome or oldest child syndrome
and another deleted character by the
looks of it in one draft may had a baby
sibling this most likely was in a pretty
early draft of the movie with the kooky
ants at the funeral it added to the
mother-daughter dynamic to have may be
the only child so she could be
completely smothered by her mother's
love and expectations and not have that
attention divided between another child
although it would have been added
responsibility and expectations put on
may so perhaps they could have worked a
sibling into the mix either way not
necessary
number 13
we're going to get real for a second now
disney has been going through some
serious controversy this past bit over
what's been going on in florida and it's
theorized that there are lgbtq plus
scenes that have been cut out of turning
red priya obviously has affections for
the goth girl at the party but their
moments together are slim to none and
even downright jarring given there's
just a tiny knot at the moment the two
characters share pixar employees across
the movies are frustrated and have been
coming out to say that they have
constantly been shut down trying to
include more lgbtq plus content
number fourteen torontonians know best
we bet they pointed it out first one
mistake that wasn't caught until it was
already released on disney plus was the
toronto streetcar you don't need a
steering wheel when the streetcar
follows a track the old streetcars just
had buttons now the new high-tech ones
have multiple screens but still
no steering wheel number 15. last time
we checked the superpower was to turn
into a panda not to conjure incense
there was also one we mistake when
manghan's may incent sticks ming is
holding 4 and she gives may three then
ming is still holding three
number 16 we're refraining from making a
joke about sight when mei's dad is
making food in true anime fashion his
glasses get steamed up when he wipes
them clean he only wipes one lens but
suddenly both are clear okay well thanks
for listening so the creative team had
to make some hard choices cutting out so
much juicy stuff but we have to say
we're glad they stuck with the plotline
they did there's no space for gangsters
in this story there was barely space for
the kooky ants she won't hug me ever
okay she hates me deep trauma wild
raging fires and a heartbreaking
situation we nearly had a significantly
more emotional story in enganto we are
covering the darker alternate endings
that almost made it to the screen
bruno makes bad things happen number one
time to get the tissues okay so we did
still lose pedro in the film but at one
time there was a possibility that it was
so much worse abuela alma's love was
going to pass away at the river at the
same time that alma was giving birth to
the triplets talk about devastating at
least in our version pedro got to meet
and say goodbye to his children and to
be there to support alma
number two and then there was alma
knowing pedro wouldn't have been able to
meet his triplets is heartbreaking
enough but poor alma would have faced an
even more intense and tragic experience
being pulled between the joy of having
her children and the heartbreak of
losing the love of her life and her
co-parent loss is never easy but these
moments happening at the same time could
have made alma's relationship with her
children much more difficult
number three you never know what you'll
find when you go to a place you used to
call home at one point in the
development of the movie mirabelle was
seen running away from the city meaning
abuela had to go back to the place she'd
run away from to find her when back in
town she'd stumble upon a mural
dedicated to her love pedro with this
quote to love it all is to love entirely
and if that weren't emotional enough as
it is abuela alma was going to stay by
the mural side all night long eventually
after finding mirabelle we discovered
the truth as abuela shared what had kept
her walls up
after i lost him
i was so afraid
i couldn't bear the thought of losing
anyone else
number four so many apologies so little
time
understanding why abuela was hurting so
much led to a different apology that
involved her explaining that her
deep-rooted fear of the miracle actually
made her forget who the miracle was for
abuela also carried the blame for
pedro's death feeling that it was
because she left the city that she lost
him and while it would have explained
why she was so scared of losing anyone
else this heartbreaking turn would have
wrecked us
number five fights between family
members can get pretty vicious
while it was abuela and mirabelle that
faced tough conflict together an
alternate ending saw mirabelle and her
mother julieta having a brutal and
heartbreaking argument one that would
upset mirabel so much that casita would
fall to ruins as a result of it number
six
this house is on fire yikes flames
nearly took down the casa madrigal and
what was left was meant to be a deeply
haunting image there was an alternate
end that saw casita burn to the ground
an especially painful turn of events
considering the candle was what kept it
going for so long after the tragic
burning a haunting scene would have
taken the place of the beloved madrigal
home only doors and windows left
floating among the ashes with an
especially dark and kind of threatening
looking spear left in the rubble which
was meant to be the remaining cracks of
the house going this dark would have
made for a very different feeling than
what we got
number seven someone call the doctor
possibilities for how casita could
suffer were extremely varied and one
alternate storyline for casita saw it
showing signs of illness physically
storyboards that didn't make the cut
show the paintings and photos hung up on
the walls of cassita going blank a sign
that the home was experiencing a kind of
brain fog at one point even the yellow
butterflies went dark seeing such a
major loss and darkness in the house
would have made the concern for
cassita's deterioration way more intense
in the end we hate to see cacita hurting
[Music]
you got this
just gonna save the miracle
number eight there's a new patriarch in
town and his name is agustin
in another version of the film agustin
was the one who decided to build the
madrigal home even after being warned
specifically not to this man was very
different from the one we got to know to
paint a bit of a picture
he had a mustache at the age of four
knowing that it's not too surprising
that even after a mysterious woman gave
him an intense warning not to build the
house he opted to go against her advice
this certainly doesn't sound like the
agustin we know and love and we would
have gotten quite a different movie if
this had been the reality
number nine you never know what you'll
find in a river if you thought casita
was magical this river is next level an
alternate storyline saw mirabel
nietzsche find her abuela how did she do
it
by following the magical river which
would have in actuality been abuela's
hair the journey mirabelle took would
have seen her exploring more of alma's
origin story and journeying through her
past uncovering all the trauma and
heartache she'd had this detail in
seeing just how long and deep that river
was would have brought a much more
intense vibe to the film highlighting
the true depth of abuela sorrow in this
case
this river is where we were
given our miracle number 10 it would
have been an ugly sight
sisters can fight there's no doubt about
it but one version of encanto saw a
pretty intense scrap between isabella
and mirabelle that's right we almost saw
these two totally duking it out but it
just didn't feel right to see that kind
of violence in their relationship so the
team decided to scrap it who would have
guessed the fights that we got were the
toned down versions
the only thing you have ever done for me
nothing is messed up number eleven there
were other options and they were
shockingly different from the oso suave
mariano isabella had our eyes on a
different character one we never got to
meet named bubo marquez this suitor was
meant to be a man from the city with a
modern and unique style to those in the
village meaning he stood out quite a bit
oh and in terms of personality this guy
was meant to be quite the goofy dork
which no doubt would have made for some
fun moments
number 12. chispy the capybara almost
wound up stealing the scene while many
alternate story lines in encanto made
for a much darker ending there was one
post-credits scene that was cut that
ended on a much funnier and perkier note
the beloved chispy the capybara wound up
being drenched by cassita an adorable
and hilarious scene that luckily did
wind up being released later on
wait a second
raya the warrior is here but she almost
faced a much much darker ending in the
film raya and the last dragon hit us in
all the right field spots but knowing
that certain characters almost didn't
return has us completely rethinking what
the movie could have been my girl ryan
and i are gonna fix the world bring
everyone back
had disney chosen to go with their much
darker alternate ending sisu truly would
have been the last dragon in the ending
we saw sisu and all her dragon siblings
return but it turns out that there was a
potential we wouldn't see any of the
dragons ever again the reason they
considered this ending is that it would
have reinforced the idea that sisu
couldn't just sweep in and solve all the
problems it was up to people trusting
each other and working together to
overcome hardship
considering that reasoning we can
understand how impactful a message the
alternate ending would have given the
debate was a long and tough one as the
creators didn't want to forego the
message they wanted to reach audiences
but in the end they decided they wanted
to bring a happy ending to the screen
the mystical ending we see in the movie
is actually more authentic from a
cultural perspective we're so glad they
chose to embrace that both out of
respect for the cultural ethos as well
as the fact that it would have been
heartbreaking to lose sisu forever well
compliments to the chef
we loved seeing elsa's portrayal of the
fifth dragon oh wait we meant sisu sisu
is the fifth dragon elsa is the fifth
spirit of course
though that's not all the two films have
in common
remember that dark alternate ending we
were just talking about
well the alternate ending from frozen 2
was eerily similar elsa who also looks
extremely similar to sisu for a dragon
and a human anyway
nearly passed away forever as well the
endings the creators wound up going with
fortunately involved happier outcomes
with the two beloved characters
returning to life unscathed
even the way they're brought back is
similar thanks to her dragon siblings
sisu ends up being resurrected
fortunately for the disney world
siblings never failed to rescue as anna
did the same for elsa and frozen too
remember when everyone was turned into a
statue in ryan the last dragon
well also knows how they feel since of
course she spent some time as a frozen
statue herself
on a bit of a happier note the
commonalities between elsa and sisu's
water-based powers are unmistakable that
blue glow this this is my little sister
amba's magic i got the glow yeah we've
seen that before how about those
graceful moves across water pads and
seemingly effortless soaring sisu has
some seriously strong elsa vibes there's
no denying it
my big brother pengu's magic
there was one other pretty significant
similarity between frozen 2 and ryan the
last dragon and that was the question of
raya and elsa's sexuality there was
strong speculation that elsa was meant
to be queer though the confirmation of
this theory we hoped to get frozen too
never came to pass
the idea that raya is queer and has
feelings for namari is definitely
floating in our minds
if there is a sequel fingers crossed
then disney has another shot to bring
the first openly queer character to the
screen this would be a huge step for the
disney franchise and brought a
representation of the society we
actually live in
we're not the only ones rooting for this
coupling though the voice of raya kelly
marie tran has expressed her excitement
over the speculations from audiences
since she herself thought the same doing
the film and was rooting for them trans
said she loved their relationship and
hopes that if there is a sequel we'll
get to see their relationship really
blossom thank you deborah
you've been
very helpful
we're already thinking of their couple
names
what will they be
namaya
rayari
either way we're rooting for them
there is one other detail that makes us
believe there really could be something
more between ray and namari
and that's the fact that the scene that
was rewritten the most was the meeting
scene between the two when they were
young since their reconciliation at the
end is so crucial their meeting had to
have just the right feeling the many
rewrites tried to create the most
authentic vulnerable and delicate scene
they could
this kind of effort wouldn't be put in
if the relationship wasn't so
significant who knows maybe one of the
versions included a stronger inkling of
romance
all the indicators are there and with
the wild success of raya and the last
dragon we might just see a defining
romance come to the screen in a sequel
our fingers are crossed for team nemaya
or team rayari either works
i love you
an act of true love without a frozen
heart making a satisfying finale can be
tough and these disney flicks almost
ended a bit differently disney is known
for giving audiences happy endings where
everything is tied with a neat little
bow these flicks from the mouse house
originally had much different third acts
than what we got in the final product
from giant sea monster battles and the
end of magic to leaving the jungle let's
see which disney movies originally had
darker endings you wouldn't kill your
old uncle
i'm like you
the ending of pixar's sea monster fable
luca won over the hearts of audiences
around the world and even made them
weepy what's interesting is that the
film almost took a different route in
its third act and would have played up
the humans vs sea monster feud that
looms over the film initially the climax
would have centered around alberto
transforming into a giant kraken with
luka ultimately having to stand up
against the humans for his misunderstood
friend
the luca team eventually decided to
lower the stakes and give the film a
more simple resolution which certainly
worked in the film's favor they are
the winners
in the conclusion of reya and the last
dragon after being shot by namari sisu
comes back to life alongside all the
other dragons surprisingly the
filmmakers initially debated whether or
not sisu and the other dragons should
return or if a resurrected sisu should
remain the last dragon in order to stay
true to the east asian themes the
creative team decided to stick with a
happier ending and one that promoted
prosperity
hope you don't mind
she brought some friends
[Music]
while pixar's soul ends with joe getting
another chance to live his life on earth
and make his lifelong dreams come to
fruition that wasn't always the case the
folks at pixar initially debated about
whether or not the film should end with
joe passing on to the great beyond
instead of getting another chance on
earth multiple endings were thrown
around but the crew soon figured out how
they could have joe return to earth
without betraying the themes of the
story or the audience so we all decided
to give you another chance
onward is the rare pixar film that is
notably absent of a clear villain but in
the initial stages of the film that
wasn't the case story supervisor kelsey
mann revealed that in the earlier stages
of the film there was a true villain who
was guarding the hidden gem needed to
bring back ian and barley's late father
the film's crew ended up scrapping the
character as they couldn't figure out a
real motive or purpose for a villainous
character
wow that's
really terrible
i know
part of frozen's popularity can be
credited to how the film handles the
themes of sisterhood between anna and
elsa the film may not have been
successful if the team at disney decided
to go with their original plans producer
peter delveco revealed that anna and
elsa weren't always supposed to be
sisters as elsa was initially planned to
be the villain of the film in an attempt
to make the film more similar to its
source material hans christian
andersen's the snow queen in another
twist the film would have ended in a
giant ice battle with anna and elsa
right in the center of it no i'm not
leaving without you elsa yes you are if
tangled had stayed closer to the
original source material the film would
have featured mother gothel tricking
flynn into believing that rapunzel was
no more in retaliation flynn would have
thrown himself from the tower only to be
saved by a bush that caused him to lose
his eyesight instead the filmmakers went
a different route giving the characters
a much happier ending with rapunzel
reuniting with her parents and marrying
flynn the film almost ended differently
until the release of a certain
documentary made the creative team
reconsider the film originally had the
characters of destiny bailly and hank
being left behind at the marine park
after watching the sea world expose
documentary blackfish the film's crew
reconsidered and decided that the
characters needed an ending where they
were happier and truly free well i guess
we'll go back home and uh brush up on
the anemone the little mermaid's climax
almost took a darker turn and originally
featured a sequence where ursula kidnaps
eric and attempts to drown him
underneath the waves the film's crew
thought twice about the scene and deemed
it too violent which led them to change
it to eric defeating ursula and rescuing
ariel while sailing a wrecked ship
everyone knows the ending of tarzan
where jane and her father decide to
abandon civilization and stay in the
jungle with tarzan but the film's ending
almost went in the exact opposite
direction that would have been more
similar to its source material featuring
tarzan leaving his ape family behind and
heading to human civilization to live
with jane
directors chris buck and kevin lima
ultimately decided against this as they
didn't want to have the titular hero
abandon his family
sarabi and i didn't see you at the
presentation of simba that was today
the lion king is already one of disney's
darker animated films but it almost had
a much darker finale the film's final
showdown between simba and scar had
initially gone down differently as
storyboards reveal that scar
successfully threw his nephew off pride
rock before ultimately falling off
himself and succumbing to the flames
simba is ultimately shown to be alive as
a tree had broken his fall the disney
execs likely saw this ending as too
intense for children and had the
animation team change it to scar being
eaten alive by the hyenas this
admittedly is still pretty dark i've got
to take you back to the man village the
man village disney's animated jungle
book ends with mowgli falling for a girl
and following her back to the man
village but originally the film didn't
end there in fact earlier versions of
the film followed mowgli reuniting with
his mother as well as a time jump
revealing that he is now at odds with
the animals that raised him if that
wasn't enough the film would have ended
with mowgli returning to the jungle to
hunt down the villainous sheer khan with
a rifle spooky i need crews never mind
that now no i need her back here now get
her back
cars 3 ends with aspiring racer cruz
ramirez taking lightning mcqueen's spot
in the penultimate race the film almost
featured an ending where crews didn't
get her chance to show off her racing
skills and instead had lightning winning
the race and the film would have ended
with the start of a mentorship is it
safe i guess i'll find out
the incinerator scene in toy story 3 is
one of the most emotionally intense
sequences in any disney movie director
lee unkrich revealed that he and the
team behind the film had actually made
an alternate cut where it ends right
when woody buzz and the gang are about
to meet their untimely end in the
incinerator cutting out the moment where
they are saved by the aliens this cut of
the film was obviously never meant to be
released and was only made as a
practical joke thank goodness
we're just here for him
the climactic chase in lilo and stitch
almost went down differently initially
featuring stitch hijacking a commercial
airplane and flying through the city in
order to rescue lilo crashing into
several buildings in the process due to
tragic events that occurred during the
time of the film's production the
animators came to the decision to
reanimate the scene so it wouldn't
resemble the recent tragedy with the
plane being changed to a starship and
the buildings into mountains toy story 4
certainly concluded on an emotional note
albeit it was one that felt appropriate
director josh cooley revealed that the
initial ending was going to go a
different route with woody and bo peep
parting ways
woody would go back to be with bonnie
while beau peep gives up her status as a
lost toy and goes to live with harmony
in the end cooley found that this ending
would go against the film's message of
accepting change and instead had woody
join beau as a lost toy
to
infinity and beyond hey hey hey hey
hello
look i'm not supposed to be here soul
was so packed with references to classic
pixar films that there was a whole scene
dedicated to them but did you spot them
all carl from up riley's broccoli pizza
an alternate ending those are just a few
of seoul's hidden secrets here's what
you might have missed it says take one
don't
or do okay
so first things first
if you haven't watched seoul yet there
are some definite spoilers ahead we
can't talk about references in a pixar
movie without mentioning the iconic
pizza planet truck it makes an
appearance in almost every pixar film
and in seoul it's hidden in the hall of
everything the hall is basically a room
filled with references to other pixar
movies there is a ferris wheel from toy
story 4 the balloon and spirit of
adventure blimp from up and the axiom
from wall-e there's even a monorail in
reference to the incredibles 2 an aztec
temple from coco this isn't a true then
you're all really out there and the
small orange boat and whale in the sky
are likely references to finding dory
there's also this large strangely shaped
object in the background that's probably
the big rock known as willy's butte from
cars pixar's short films also get a
shout out in this scene there's a
chessboard that pays homage to jerry's
game and a canoe that references loop
these souls need their spark and that's
where you come in when a new soul is
looking for its spark we see it give
archery a shot the fact that the soul is
shooting at three targets reminds us of
brave when merida shoots at three
targets to try and win her own hand in
marriage if you were admiring 22's home
before entering the zone you probably
also spotted the pixar ball hiding under
a table it's not colored in this scene
so it's more subtle wait are you
actually helping me but there's no doubt
that that's the ball that has made
appearances in almost every pixar film
there is a very subtle nod to monsters
inc when joe and 22 get on the subway
the number on the subway car is two
three one nine
23-19 we have a 23-19
which also happens to be the contaminant
code featured in monsters inc whenever a
child or something that has touched a
child infiltrates monstropolis
soul has a lot in common with inside out
in the sense that it deals with a lot of
mental health and finding purpose since
pete doctor also directed inside out he
included a few references to riley and
her family riley's dad works for a
startup called brang and he wears their
shirt in seoul an ad for the company
appears on the new york city subway the
full ad is never seen but it's
definitely the same logo a reference to
riley herself pops up in the hall of
everything scene when joe is trying to
inspire 22's spark with some good
old-fashioned pizza on the top shelf
there's a broccoli pizza which is too
random not to reference riley and her
mom stopping for a slice
just smell it can't neither can you what
you're right i can't smell
when 22 changes her voice this whole
place is a hypothetical i could sound
like this if i wanted to might have
noticed that it sounds exactly like carl
friedrichsen from up oh yeah that was
good
here let me talk to him
that's the voice of ed asner who also
voiced carl and it's no surprise he's
included since seoul's director pete
doctor also worked on up
when joe as a cat walks past a rat
hauling a piece of pizza the first thing
that popped into your head was probably
pizza wrapped pete doctor included this
moment which references the famous rat
caught on camera in new york city to
forever immortalize him in film it's
also a bit of a cheeky reference to a
justice famous pixar rat remy from
ratatouille another reference hidden in
the hall of everything is the pixar lamp
known as luxo jr the lamp that you
probably know best from the pixar title
screen actually starred in its very own
short film in 1986
but in the hall we can see it inspiring
a new soul if you're a pro at pixar
references you might already know that
a113 appears in a lot of pixar films
it's not a reference to just one movie
but to the famous cal arts classroom
where many pixar alumni studied in seoul
there's a blank street sign towards the
right side of the screen in the hall of
everything that reads a113
we're going to go back to the hall of
everything for a moment to point out all
the inside out references there because
there are just so many that are specific
to pete doctor's previous pixar film
yeah it's good what happened with the
playoffs there are a few references to
san francisco like the golden gate
bridge and a trolley but there are also
some more direct references to riley's
mind it looks like there's a princess
castle in the back which gets demolished
and inside out when riley grows older
and forgets about it there's also a
bulldozer which was used to push
forgotten memories into the memory dump
even the trampoline could be a reference
to the one riley jumped on with her
parents soul also contains a subtle
reference to walt disney himself
where
are we in dr borjensen's hall of you we
see a statue of the famed psychologist
where he's standing and pointing to his
right arm while his left holds a child's
hand
this pose is just like the partner's
statue found at disneyland and magic
kingdom where walt disney points down
main street while folding mickey mouse's
hand 22's home is full of name tags from
previous mentors but there are three
names in particular that are significant
to disney and pixar fans the first is
joe grant a disney animation legend who
worked on classic films like snow white
and the seven dwarves and even helped
pete doctor on monsters inc the second
is joe rant a disney legend who won an
academy award for the toy story
screenplay and was also the voice of
heimlich in a bug's life how about the
nice tasty vermont
last but not least is jack kirby who was
a famous comic book artist writer and
editor at marvel and helped create
iconic characters like spider-man and
captain america
if the lost souls and the zone remind
you of something you're probably
thinking of the memory dump from inside
out the darkness represented in this
scene is very similar to the kind of
darkness lost souls experience in soul
both films teach us that having
compassion for these negative feelings
can help you learn to coexist with them
and even appreciate them
nothing i just need to fill out that
last box i give up
[Music]
terry might have been trying to get joe
to move on like he's supposed to but
there's no true villain in seoul in fact
you might even say that joe is his own
villain just like how 22's fear to live
is what's really standing in their way
but according to pete docter there
almost was a more villainous character
david diggs voices paul from the
barbershop who basically just pesters
joe but he was almost more of an
antagonist who would have been a bigger
obstacle to joe's success but in the end
joe calling out paul for being jealous
was all he really needed to do to defeat
this naysayer he's just criticizing me
to cover up the pain of his own failed
dreams
and he had enough of a challenge dealing
with his own insecurities and the
pressures of life so a true villain was
never really needed just like there was
almost a villain soul almost had an
entirely different ending pete doctor
revealed that there were a few different
ideas floating around about how to
properly end the movie some of them were
funny and some of them were sad but one
of the ones they almost chose involved
joe actually moving on to the great
beyond
but just like the jerry's they decided
to give him a second chance at life and
end the film on an inspiring note now
that joe really understands what it
means to live he gets to go and give it
another shot pixar always likes to hide
a reference to their next film in their
movies and it's usually the kind of
thing you don't really notice until
watching it again one of the easter eggs
for seoul appeared in onward where you
can see a record of the dorothea
williams quartet in the case of seoul
this reference actually appeared early
on in one of the trailers luca is
scheduled for release in 2021 and when
joe and 22 walk past a travel agency you
can spot a poster for porto rosso a
place you can get to by flying luca
airlines any other hidden secrets you
spotted in seoul
and what did you think of the movie let
us know in the comment section below
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time